all right everybody in our first story
today the constitution dao has raised
over 46 million dollars to buy one of
the 13 copies of the constitution that
are still remaining of course the united
states uh constitution and
early reports are that the constitution
now won the bidding it was actually
quite thrilling sotheby's hosted an
auction
uh quote of one of just 13 copies of the
official edition of the constitution
surviving from a printing of 500 issued
for submission to the continental
congress and for use of the delegates to
the constitutional convention they did
make a note at the beginning of the
auction
that there were two or three more copies
that they i guess did not originally
know so the denominator of the number of
copies of this is obviously important in
terms of
the value of it i if there were more of
them if there were 200 of these they
obviously wouldn't be as scarce and so
they probably wouldn't go for as much
i got to know who was on the other side
of this because they were going back and
forth between two different bidders one
of the bidders was named brooke
apparently she won so she was
representing the constitution dow
she was kind of funny she was kind of
laughing a little bit or having fun with
it and then i guess the other one was
david um and uh he seemed a little bit
more stiff upper lip and a little boring
and dry
with his uh
additional bids but very quickly brook
came over the top and just said 30
million so this thing started and they
were going 20 million 21 million boom
brook says 30 million so that was kind
of to tell during this very exciting
auction i got very excited about her
auctions are cool
um
that they come over the top and that
means either it's like a saudi prince or
something that was like one of the early
reports that they might have been
competing against the saudi prince for
this
uh which would be kind of ironic uh or
paradoxical for saudi prince to buy the
constitution
to put in saudi arabia a museum there
that would be uh quite a
yeah i think paradoxical would be the
proper
descriptor of that turn of events um so
if you don't know what a dao is let's
explain what that is it means a
decentralized autonomous organization it
means a group of people acting together
and in this new definition it's a group
of people
who donated a bunch of
a crypto in this case ethereum
and
the concept behind the dow is that you
and endows are kind of like saying
corporations you can do a lot of
different things with them it's kind of
like saying paper you can do a lot of
different things with them
and dabs mean a lot of different things
to different people but essentially
means the people put the money and get a
vote typically to measure it with the
amount of money they put in
and then when it comes to issues of
governance they would vote on what would
happen and they would have ownership
however
this dow was not based on ownership when
you put money into it
you would be not putting money in in
order to uh
see the
constitution increase in value in other
words if this goes from 41 million to
400 million you're not going to 10x your
money you don't actually own it and this
was pitched as own the constitution
we're buying the constitution
so i think
this auction it sounds crazy but there's
a chance this could be reversed or there
could be a problem here because this
probably broke securities law uh and i
think the sec will look into this i know
this sounds crazy and you think i'm a
crypto hater i love dows i think they're
very awesome and very interesting new
format however to the best of my
knowledge this was not done with
accredited investors in other words
people who are allowed
to invest in these things i don't think
there was any kyc involved in this know
your customer and if that's the case and
they were pitching this and doing
general solicitation in order to do this
legally here in the united states
uh which is why a lot of crypto projects
do not accept american investors because
we have rules here about uh capital
formation uh which i'm pretty familiar
with they would have had to do it like
republic or seed invest for equity
crowdfunding sites do which is they
would limit the amount of money you
could put in there's a holding period of
30 days you can change your mind you
have to file a bunch of accounting rules
what's great about a dow is they can be
set up instantly like we saw with this
constitution now i mean it came together
very quickly because all you're doing is
throwing money from your wallet into
another one paying some gas fees and
you're done well
that is going to be the crux of this
issue because if americans put this in
here and they thought they were owning
the constitution which is what they said
in all the marketing we're going to buy
it we're going to which means we're
going to own it yada yada and i was
going back and forth with some people on
twitter who were saying hey we're buying
it hey we own it and i was like are you
sure you own it yeah they lost okay we
got breaking live news it looks like
the constitution now lost community we
did not win the bid for the copy of this
constitution while this wasn't the
outcome we hoped for
we still made history tonight with the
constitution is the largest crowd fund
for physical object that we are aware of
crypto or fiat we are so incredibly
grateful to have done this together with
with you all and are still in shock that
we even got this far sotheby's has never
worked with a dow community before we
broke records for the most money
crowdfunded in less than 72 hours that's
the most amazing thing about this we've
educated the an entire cohort of people
around the world from museum curators to
archer and art directors to our
grandmothers asking us what each is when
they read about us in the news about the
possibilities of web 3 and on the fl
this is really written poorly and on the
flip side com many of you have learned
about what it means to steward an asset
like the u.s constitution across museums
and collections or watch an art auction
for the first time we had 17 437 donors
with a median donation size of 206
dollars wow that's like some bernie
sanders uh strategy there really small
donations
a significant percentage of these
donations came from wallets that were
initialized for the first time in other
words uh people specifically bought
crypto to do this which is really cool
you will be able to get a refund of your
pro rata amount effectively minus gas
fees through juicebox
please expect more details about this
tomorrow our team has not slept for the
past week and we're giving people the
night to get some rest before we're back
at it tomorrow am each one of you were a
part of this we want to also thank our
partners in this work almeida research
endowment ftx us juice box morning brew
and syndicate dao
so these are really interesting times um
back to the legality of this the
legality of this is pretty clear if
you're going to do something like this
you need to have accredited investors
only if you do accredited investors
there are limitations on that my
understanding is 250 people up to 10
million or 99 you can go above it in
other words like a venture fund
and if you were to do this the way they
wanted to do it they were saying you
have governance you can vote but you
don't own it but we're buying it and
you're owning it so the messaging was
not clear but that's great because since
they didn't win it this doesn't have to
be reversed there doesn't need to be an
sec investigation into this if they
broke security's law because everything
would just get their money back minus
gas fees and the gas fees are probably
somewhere in the neighborhood of 15 i
saw when people were doing these because
ethereum i guess is very busy and
time on the blockchain costs money i
mean i don't know why ethereum is so
expensive still and that's why salon is
doing so well but ethereum does have a
plan to make things much cheaper so
continuing on here what an amazing
moment in time to see this many people
come together and i think
in order to contextualize this what i
what i've been thinking about is what
else can we do
because if you can put 40 million
dollars together
uh you know this quickly what is the
possibility
if instead of 17 000 17 million people
got involved well there could be a
thousand x you know uh what we just saw
we could see a billion dollars show up
for a cause and if that seems crazy to
you just remember
uh this all reminds me of live aid and
live aid raised 127 million dollars we
had this incredible concert all of this
money was raised to feed africa and to
help people survey in africa
if something trends like this through
social media and you really can just
move money freely without having to
worry about governments getting involved
in regulations
uh we could see crazy things happen now
we could also see crazy amounts of fraud
who knows people could abscond with the
money
but maybe people should be able to do
what they want with their own money is
something i've always said so i don't
want to be hypocritical here
if the donation size was 200 and
somebody committed a crime here then you
have the legal system to come after them
okay sock to compliance is critically
important why if you don't have sock too
tight you're going to lose major
customers you just can't close them it's
that simple and guess what vanta
v-a-n-t-a is going to give you 1000 off
your sock 2 compliance vantis compliance
software makes it easy to get and to
renew your sock too they continually
test against technical and non-technical
soc2 requirements they partner with over
two dozen audit firms who have been
trained to file sock tool reports
directly within vanta and on average
vanta customers are sock to compliant in
just two to four weeks compared to three
to five months without vanta take it
from kitty hawk ceo john he grains he
heard me read vanta's ad and emailed me
about how much she loves vanta i'm
kidding you not john told me that vanto
was essential in helping kitty hawk get
sock 2 compliant so they could target
larger customers if you haven't heard of
sock 2 you will when you get to those
big customers so
unlock the big sales and give your
employees time to work on more business
critical assignments like your product
like sales
fantas giving twist listeners a one
thousand dollar discount on their
subscription at
once again vanta.com twist for one
thousand dollars off v-a-n-t-a.com
twist